today we're talking about pub/sub in
cloud monitoring and an AI searchable
video archive I'm reto Meier and welcome
to this week in cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news from the safety
of home cloud monitoring is a service
that can alert you through a variety of
notification channels which now includes
cloud pops up pops up is a published
subscribe queue that lets you build
loosely coupled applications with this
integration currently in beta you can
create automated and programmatic
workflows in response to alerts for
example by integrating with third-party
providers to create an incident response
workflow we've just published the first
episode of Google Cloud drawing board a
new video series that breaks down
various Google cloud tools and shows you
how they work and what they can do in
the first video pre our cover Gardea
covers compute engine showing off
various use cases and how you can use it
for your projects while managing your
costs last week Dale Markowitz shared a
post explaining how she used Google
cloud to build an AI searchable video
archive as a Father's Day gift she took
over four hundred and fifty six hours of
digitized footage in Google Drive and
created a way for her dad to rediscover
forgotten moments and then she turned
around and showed us how she did it it's
a pretty fantastic read and it
demonstrates that while building a
searchable indexed video archive is fun
for personal projects it's also useful
for businesses looking to automatically
generate metadata for large video
datasets caption and translate clips or
quickly search brand and creative assets
we're only three weeks away from Google
cloud next for 2020 we've reimagined
this annual conference into a nine week
digital event there's a lot to explore
so we've created session packages to
help attendees discover and explore
sessions that they're interested in
check these out for yourself and be sure
to add a package to your playlist so
that you don't miss a thing if you want
to read more about these announcements
or see the full list check out the link
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you